Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
We already know that by using a computer,
we can simulate fluids and we can simulate
hair.
But what about simulating both of them at
the same time?
This paper is about liquid-hair interaction
and simulating the dynamics of wet hair.
Our seasoned Fellow Scholars immediately know
that this episode is going to be ample in
amazing slow motion footage.
I hope I didn't mess up with any of them,
you will see soon if this is the case or not!
Before we start talking about it, I'd like
to note the following remarkable features:
the authors uploaded a supplementary video
in 4k resolution, executable files for their
technique for all 3 major operating systems,
data assets, and they also freshly revealed
the full source code of the project.
Hell yeah!
I feel in heaven.
A big, Two Minute Papers style hat tip to
the authors for this premium quality presentation.
If this paper were a car, it would definitely
be a Maserati or a Mercedes.
This technique solves the equations for liquid
motion along every single hair strand, computes
the cohesion effects between the hairs, and
it can also simulate the effect of water dripping
off the hair.
Feast your eyes on these absolutely incredible
results.
The main issue with such an idea is that the
theory of large, and small-scale simulations
are inherently different, and in this case,
we need both.
The large-scale simulator would be a standard
program that is able to compute how the velocity
and pressure of the liquid evolves in time.
However, we also wish to model the water droplets
contained within one tiny hair strand.
With a large-scale simulator, this would take
a stupendously large amount of time and resources,
so the key observation is that a small-scale
fluid simulator program would be introduced
take care of this.
However, these two simulators cannot simply
coexist without side effects.
As they are two separate programs that work
on the very same scene, we have to make sure
that as we pass different quantities between
them, they will still remain intact.
This means that a drop of water that gets
trapped in a hair strand has to disappear
from the large-scale simulator, and has to
be readded to it when it drips out.
This is a remarkably challenging problem.
But with this, we only scratched the surface.
Make sure to have a look at the paper that
has so much more to offer, it is impossible
to even enumerate the list of contributions
within in such a short video.
The quality of this paper simply left me speechless
and I would encourage you to take a look as
well.
And while this amazing footage is rolling,
I would like to let you know that Two Minute
Papers can exist because of your support through
Patreon.
Supporters of the series gain really cool
perks like watching every single one of these
episodes in early access.
I am super happy to see how many of you decided
to support the series, and in return, we are
able to create better and better videos for
you.
Thank you again, you Fellow Scholars are the
most amazing audience.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!